welcome to another technology tuesday
where i
answer your tech questions to help you
grow your business today's question
comes from
linda kingsbury who wrote in to me on
youtube love you guys
and said question about evernote so she
said our tags and categories the same
i would love to have more categories in
each notebook and even subcategories
how do i do this categories and
subcategories in each notebook
seem easier to use than tags that are in
a separate section thanks to your great
videos
okay so linda great question categories
is not an official evernote term they
don't they don't recognize the word
category so there's a couple of ways
that you can
categorize your content in evernote and
i'm gonna hop quickly over to my
computer so i could show you so this is
my evernote and i have
two main stacks that i use here the
first is for my business knows and the
second is for tds notes which is a
another business a dance company i'm
involved in and anytime i know that i'm
gonna i'm going to need a lot of
different
notes and i want to categorize them into
different folders
or in this case notes or notebooks then
i'll create a stack for it
and so it just gives you an extra layer
of of categories so an example if i
click on my business notes stack
these will be all of the notes that i
have in my business notes if i click the
arrow to expand
you'll see all the different notebooks
that i have inside
so for example one might be articles to
read so these are articles that i've
clipped that i want to read using
evernote's
web clipper and then in here are my
individual notes so i have
three potential layers for any project
that i'm working on you have the
individual notes
that then you can group together into
notebooks
so the the articles the individual note
might be
how can i re-engage inactive subscribers
that's an individual note
it's grouped under the notebook articles
to read
which is then grouped under the stock
business notes so you have three levels
if you want to
and i like they're folders i like having
folders i think in folders
i i keep my files in folders on my
computer
so it lets you go you know folder folder
into a note so it gives you
extra uh ways to classify and categorize
your information
the tag system i'm not a huge fan of so
each of these uh each of these notes can
be tagged so if i click on this
here how do i re-engage uh inactive
subscribers i can click in here click to
add tag and i can add a tag call it
whatever i want
and then if you scroll to the left side
of your evernote
down there's an area called tags and you
can find all your tags i really honestly
just use it for government stuff my
government filing so they're
individually tagged so they're a little
bit easier to find but otherwise
my preference is to rely on the folder
option so you know you got your stack
again
the notebook and then the notes and then
i also rely on the full text search so
it's easy to find individual
documents so that's how i do it i hope
that helped linda if you have any
follow-up questions
let me know in the comments below for
those you guys watching like the video
you want to see more just like it you
can subscribe to the channel
thank you so much and i will see you
soon
hi raquel english here with mermaid
junkie tv are you on
evan's newsletter subscription if not
you should be i read every single one
and you should too ciao